[Musique]
le mesenas on pourrait dire que c'est
tout simplement le le don d'une personne
morale privé que ce soit un particulier
ou une entreprise envers une structure
d'intérêt général pour soutenir une
cause qu'elle soit culturelle
environnementale ou
[Musique]
sociétale distinguer différents types de
mesena en particulier de mesena
d'entreprise on va avoir le mesena
financier bien sûr le mesena en nature
c'est lorsque par exemple l'entreprise
va donner du matériel informatique
qu'elle n'utilise plus et puis il y a le
mesénat de
compéten là en fait il s'agit pour le
collaborateur volontaire de donner de
son temps de ses compétences de ses de
ses